hey people you know it's been kind of
like been a while since i've been on the
air you know because i've been i hadn't
been down at like that much like
recently because i mean i've been really
kind of down be you know being it being
christmas time and all that kind of
stuff you know
christmas time for most people is happy
go lucky christmas presents and all the
good [ __ ] in life and the whole family
gets together has big big bombards bar
mitzvah and all this kind of [ __ ] but
for me it's dark than a [ __ ]
because i always go back in my mind to
that crazy ass [ __ ]
of the molestation part of my life that
[ __ ] my mind up so i'm going to tell
i'm going to tell some stuff that i i've
never told anybody i'm going deep down
and tell some deep [ __ ] that i've never
told nobody i never plan on telling
about this because this this is really d
do you mean to my to my who i am my
character my personality but this is the
truth about something that i did in my
addiction
as direct cause of being molested as a
child
so i hope the people that [ __ ] my life
up that molested me as a [ __ ]
kid
can hear this [ __ ] because i'm gonna put
it out here and what i did was when i
did what i did when i did i did as a
result of you molesting me as a kid and
[ __ ] my mind up sexually
you know i was
i had a couple of girls in my house the
other day that i met here in the front
of the mission you know when they were
young and uh we did some real kinky ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] but anyway i'm going
there in the end but i'm going to tell
you how i got there you know um
like i said when chris's time come
around i think about because it was
always christmas time when these when
these [ __ ] females would make me do
all this demoralizing [ __ ] too you know
here i am [ __ ] [ __ ] seven eight
nine year old boy knowing what a [ __ ]
smell like knowing what a vagina you
feel when long what vagina felt like you
know what i'm saying that's some that's
you know and and and some of the things
that i did when i was molested as a
child by these women you know some of it
i liked i'm not gonna lie some of it i i
really liked you know it but a lot of it
has got my um
my head so [ __ ] up i remember when um
a certain person in my family you know
had me to uh watch these i was
about nine years old they had me watch
these sexual acts that they were doing
and then you know participate in this
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying and and
and that [ __ ] was foul and wrong as hell
because that's the
one one of the direct results of why i'm
[ __ ] up so [ __ ] up now today today i
want to sometimes i want to blame myself
for [ __ ] today i'm blaming other
[ __ ] because y'all shouldn't
dear me like that you know what i'm
saying got my whole life [ __ ] up so
anyway they had me with their headed
daddy and i mean i'm i guess i'm about
nine years old you know i guess the
babysitter in this dude she was [ __ ]
what i guess he was about 17 18 90
whatever but they would be they would be
on the bed you know on this dirty ass
mattress in the backyard [ __ ] and
doing all this crazy ass [ __ ] and they
made me get down and do it with them you
know here i'm nine years old man and i'm
doing this [ __ ] [ __ ] you know and it
made me it made me it made me but it
made my it [ __ ] up my mind
because i have i have a drug addiction i
have an alcohol addiction and i have a
sexual addiction that i don't like to i
don't like to i don't like to to to to
let i don't like to think about it i
like to talk about it because it's
perverted because of what i did you know
in my mind ago these two girls i had in
my house there was two of them they were
under age i know they were i know they
were but you know what my mind my
[ __ ] mind is so [ __ ] up because i
remember i mean i'mma tell you a story
about a true story i was in i was in i
was oh man i was in the seventh grade
you know and um and i had this i had
this i had this teacher you know and she
was
i'm i was gonna say her name but i had
this teacher you know and she was you
know she was a white chick man and she
had blue eyes she had problem she's
wearing she's blonde ponytails like the
girl on the on the very hair but she
looked just like that girl she always
wanted these these [ __ ] uh these
these [ __ ] uh what do you call them
there
joy hat jeans had this real tight little
ass and she had this gap between the
legs but you could see the meat couple
of vaginas coming out every time so yeah
i'm bored of my body i don't know every
year when you when you're nice where i
just got the junior high school ninth
grade and so by the way that's how many
classes in my life ever got ahead
because i would i like this i'd like for
her to come near me because she would
come near me and i would fantasize i'm
about fantasized about how i want i
wanted her to come smell her so i could
smell her vagina so when i went home and
masturbated at night i could think about
how the vagina smells and how vagina
looked and jackal those are things i
would think about so i started raising
my hand for her to come to my desk every
[ __ ] day i got in there but i was
learning i was missing i don't
understand this but i would be
understanding
so one day she caught on to what i was
doing because you know i was a little
boy but i had a pretty large dude i had
a pretty i had a pretty hunky jump down
in my pens now back in that day we wore
the 501 levi we wore them kind of tight
now they weren't we want them kind of
tight back in so you know where these
little thing that draws so if i got a if
i got a woody i mean i got a wooden you
saw it so she came back to my desk one
day you know and she knew when she
figured out what i was doing she came
back to my desk one day you know when
she
and she uh
she she caught herself going cl now that
i'm older i know what she did she caught
herself going clown me because she saw
how hard my dad got my day was oh man
that day you know fellas if you remember
we were that age when your day got hard
it was kind of hard to make that
[ __ ] go down for some reason she
so she walked up to the front of the
classroom she says now we're going to
have lewis come up here and show a
demonstration of how he got a on his
test like we do it would you come up now
now i had to get up now let me tell you
my dick was it was my day was hard i had
to get up i had to go present but i was
going to stay in front of the whole
class i had a heart on i mean i had a
real heart on so when i walked in i'm
trying i'm trying to think of sometimes
and i got my ass up last night trying to
figure something negative and then
[ __ ] wouldn't go down so i'm in
front of the classroom i'm funny cousin
i'm turning around here my dick is
thinking about my jeans and the little
chinese girl sitting right she's like oh
i was so and the teacher made it she
played she went around the front of the
crowd and she's like oh doc you you need
to go sit down oh my god oh my god you
need to go sit down but man i've never
in my life been so [ __ ] embarrassed
but she found me like that but that's
the part of the sexual addiction the
part of the perverted mind that i had is
that's how i was growing up you know i
remember
here where i'm going to go when i
america
it's hard to get this out i've never
ever ever ever ever told about this
i got hooked on my disease so bad and
i'm
i had this girlfriend that i liked a lot
in them
she dumped me for some other guy
and that hurt me so bad
i i went into a depression and i started
i became homeless and i walked the
streets so i saw this guy on the corner
of this particular city i was in i said
what are you doing me said he said want
to need a cigarette so i gave him he
gave me a cigarette i said what you
doing he said man i'm making money
that's what i need to make some money
what you doing he said i'm working the
boulevard
okay what what you talking about he said
man i'm walking down the boulevard and
i'm making money i'm getting pulled over
by people making money i said okay i'm
thinking all winning that's what [ __ ]
that sounds good to me
i go to the mission i get some clothes i
i i'm going first i start walking down
street i said no i can't
i can't i can't believe myself i said
well [ __ ] it if i go give me a bottle of
jd i won't even be thinking about what
i'm doing
i'll go i go get the ball of jd i drink
the bottle of jack dance i'm walking
down the boulevard and here comes this
little first time coming first time a
white dude pull up in a goddamn jaguar
and say hey man what you got
all right what you guys bro what you
need i said that's what i said i'm
trying to give you some crack you know
he's well no i need you but i gotta well
how much he's well how much i'm i don't
really know what i'm doing but i'm i'm
i'm figuring out what he's talking about
he says well i got
i got 50 bucks you need 50 bucks i said
yeah well what i got to do he said we'll
just get in the car and
i'm thinking what the [ __ ]
so i get in the car he wants to he wants
to suck my dick for money and i and i
but i [ __ ] did it you know i did that
[ __ ] and after i did that [ __ ] i was i
was prone never to tell nobody that was
the most insulting thing i ever did but
i was on that jack daniel but when i
took that fifty dollars i like to tell
you i took that 50 and got that dope and
never did that [ __ ] again i took that 50
dollars i went and got some more liquor
and i kept doing it
i was i was i was to do that in
i've done it in new york done it in
atlanta i've done it in san francisco i
was in here
and anyway i got to the point where
my conscience i my conscience would
never say that what i was doing was
wrong
and i recall
god i never told him and i recall this
this i recall this this
this this lady pulling over in this car
and she looked like a while she was just
like this black dresses she had a long
rack hair with blue back eyes she looked
like a demon
so there were two ladies sitting in the
back of this this suv it was i guess it
was uh uh uh uh um a range rover a big
land rover whatever that big big pretty
truck so she pulls up and she does she
has this little accident yes
what's
what's he doing here
i said well i'm trying to make two
dollars you know what i'm saying she's
like oh she says well what i had how big
is it how big is the light how big is it
i said well i pulled some i put my
shells in my pants and i pulled it out
she sticks around out the window she
grabbing she started wanking on it and
it kind of gets so hard she said well
jump in so i know i jump on in the truck
i jumped in the she was in the front and
the two
the two girls
so i thought
we're girls
we're in the back seat
she says well if you jump in the back
seat let's throw in the jump in the back
i feel another hundred dollars you know
i thought i want a hundred dollars i
threw a hundred dollars in there for you
i said oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on
they're gonna try to kill me this
[ __ ] what
i didn't give a [ __ ] i wanted it i
didn't i couldn't see
danger i couldn't see no danger in that
[ __ ] i was doing they couldn't kill me
or cluck me i asked me some [ __ ]
happened right there but this one here i
got something which i'm sitting in the
back of this [ __ ] truck and in the
back and said she's not on the range
rover they got the seats i get they got
a switch up there where you go hit the
switch
i'm like there's somebody here switching
that [ __ ] and i'm saying
what the [ __ ] did what they think to do
so she said she said she said she said
she said would say well what was rap rap
grab their [ __ ] lad and play with
their forces and i'll come down and pull
the thing down them in the middle and
i'll come stop clothic let's see it get
hard i said no [ __ ] problem let me
get my finger
so when i reach down and grab the [ __ ]
and play with the [ __ ]
what know what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like no [ __ ] never dicks
so i'm in the car
don't go tell nobody i said it i'm in
the car with two [ __ ]
transmission
now you talking about stepping down to
the beach i'm a down underbelly low down
[ __ ] so i grab the dicks on the
[ __ ] and i'm sitting in the
goddamn scene the seating on rollback
she said would be with them really from
jackie's [ __ ] but i'm gonna
give me another shot at jack give me
another set of that once the jack down
you got it in there well [ __ ]
everything i want so i'm doing this
[ __ ] [ __ ] she didn't jump back
and now in the range you got the little
little things that in the in like like a
cat in the middle they're like arm
wrestlers you can push them back and
there was so much room between them so
she's down in there now she's sucking my
leg nice it's like slightly raining
and guess who come to the window knocks
on the window with a flashlight it's the
[ __ ] sheriff
i'm getting in the truck like this she's
here and i'm here and they're like well
well somebody wanna tell me what's going
on and i look you can imagine you're
expressing everybody's face
he said wait a minute and she said ah
let me talk to y'all for the day oprah
said we're just having a little fun here
she said well the guy he's cleaned my
house for me and we just want to stop
the truck and have a little fun because
it's raining we didn't want to walk in
house we're sorry if we disrespect your
city or we'll go home or whatever we'll
it will pay whatever the cops said he
said
i'll let you guys go he said if you let
me go get my partner out of the car and
actually see because he's not going to
believe what you're waiting
at the truck they're watching all we're
not actually in there
but we're still you know in the position
so the top sauce okay you guys go i'm
gonna try to do that [ __ ] some work but
any kind of way that's that's though
that's a demon one of the one of the
deadliest thing wanting to demoralizing
things
and uh another time
oh yeah i didn't want to tell this video
it was another time i was i was in that
i went i was in in the city of hollywood
and uh i didn't really know
me not being from california i didn't
really know what was going on like that
so i met this guy you know i met this
guy you know he had his nice car and he
says well he said well you want to come
with the house you know i just got a
minute we're just trying to talk anyone
i gotta you know that house is going up
on the on the
[ __ ] had a partner where put his
basement up on it they had a pool on top
of that [ __ ] so we go out to the
pool
everything
you can think of was out there it was
men out there it was it was real there
was underage blondes out there with
women out there it was her morphine shot
it was transvestites out there
everything in the devil's book the
bevel's book alive was in that boo
uh well i i i remember standing there
thinking wow this is because it was i
mean the scenery was beautiful the pool
and the different [ __ ] around it was
beautiful but the people and in my
spirit in my spirit i said something
wrong with this [ __ ] give me a shot of
that jack daniels and i'll be all
they did right than jack they had
hennessy i got they had the hennessy and
the [ __ ] jack daniels i got the
hennessy and the jackknife and i'm
dreaming now i'm fitting in with one of
these [ __ ]
i'm talking about
how
my mind became so demoralized how that
was the norm for me
to be in that pool with these
[ __ ] man if y'all would've i
mean i'm about y'all would've saw this
[ __ ] so i'm in the [ __ ] swimming pool
and the first thing i see is this blonde
girl
she's
a little bit i remember we had a
swimming pool near my house
and i mean i'm like eight nine years old
and they and they banned me from the
pool dude i thought this [ __ ] was normal
because i would get in the swimming pool
and i would i would i would best watch
the little girls man i would i would put
my hand all in the panties and play with
it and i'm
eight nine years old and i'm playing
with the little girls vaginas and them
and i always got in and i like to grab
them by the ass and hop on the ass and
i'd get up under the water you know and
kind of squeeze on their thighs and kind
of smell i was always a little boy crazy
about the smell of a vagina you know a
little boy my mind was all distorted was
all [ __ ] up and i thought that was
normal so i'm got this one mission girl
in there and she's liking this young one
but she's up against the pool and i'm
hoping on her i'm kissing her up and i'm
like nine years old
and they said whoa whoa whoa little dude
what you doing what they told they
called and told moms hey man your son is
down in the pool like after school you
know something to die in the pool man
he's playing he's messing with the girls
come on man he he can't come here no
more
we gonna make no big issue out of it he
said but if that girl's father knew what
he was doing you know we ain't gonna
make a big issue about it because we
like the kid he's a nice kid he just he
just something wrong with him yeah wrong
with this system he says i'm wrong with
your son
so anyway i got my ass tore up
i got the [ __ ] out of me i got the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's the [ __ ] [ __ ]
feet out of me
you know [ __ ] and this is all
due to these [ __ ]
in my mind as a child man you [ __ ]
you i mean when you [ __ ] with a kid man
as a little child you [ __ ] them up you
[ __ ] their whole mother life up
you [ __ ] them up you don't think you
don't think what you're doing is
destroying a [ __ ] but they
destroyed the [ __ ] out of me my mind is
so [ __ ] fickled and [ __ ] up behind
this [ __ ]
oh man i'm almost deep corner man
[ __ ] homosexual getting money to get
good and when it got so bad too
like but it got to a point
where i was so i was what i was doing
was so demoralized you know i i couldn't
i just i just i i stopped some kind i
said you know what
when they went and started getting into
when they wanted me to get with the men
and that [ __ ] i just i couldn't i i just
some kind of way i just said [ __ ] this
[ __ ] i got a older i said man [ __ ] this
[ __ ] but i'm gonna come over that now
i'm not not hitting now here here we
around christmas time now most of this
[ __ ] just happened around christmas time
because
when i would go back it would be
surround in winter christmas time
because
i get kind of depressed you know because
i don't at least this is where i feel
nobody wants me around nobody i feel
like i felt like a sore thumb to the
family nobody really wants me around i
just have that complex about me you know
and and
and and the depression and wanted why
every time crips come out i i want i
just want to die i just want to just get
the [ __ ] out of here man i don't like
being this
dirty nasty [ __ ] up life am i you know
i don't like being here man i walk
around with a [ __ ] smile most time i
got the the the demons the entities
about about about the demoralizing sex
sexual acts that i put on the child and
i've i've never ever ever this these are
the things that come up in my in my gut
in my mind my perfect time it makes me
so goddamn depressed
i don't know i want to do crazy [ __ ] to
myself like come on and cut my neck and
[ __ ] that's why i mean go to the
medicine cabinet and all this
[ __ ] medicine
so
i'm going the other two two or three
days ago it was about to rain
and i'm down there at the [ __ ]
mission oh oh oh oh two weeks ago
this one two weeks ago i was um it's
coming it's all coming back two weeks
ago
i said god damn i'm gonna i'm gonna tell
it i'm gonna go because
i don't have money for my daughter my
daughter needs my money my daughter i'm
always alone behind miranda i need this
cold i need to
turn the gas on so i get my heater on
and turn my game cable off my tv i say
you know what i was i was drinking one
day i was drunk one day you know and
then the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
demoralizing thoughts well [ __ ] it i go
walk the bullet and try to make me some
money [ __ ] with my own ass i so try to
you know at this age
you know in the [ __ ] about it i've
never i've never i've never i've never
i've never thought i've never even even
as my addiction gets worse i've never
thought to do that again until this
until now
that because i started thinking about
what i used to do and i said well
[ __ ] i'm already i'm already cursed
i'm already damaged i've even tried to
go out there i mean i went out there you
know i didn't have nobody [ __ ] me
didn't happen but i went out there you
know i [ __ ] actually went out there
and tried it with my whole ass you know
i still got the body and [ __ ] but i you
know anyway i just i i couldn't i
i couldn't do that [ __ ] so what i did
was i came home i'm depressed like a
[ __ ] you know i'm thinking i'm
i'm so desperate for money i want to i
know why people are breaking the windows
and doing all that crazy i even thought
about busting it going down to the
target and busting the [ __ ]
window off and going to steal me some
[ __ ] equipment for my parents when i
because they want me to come to this big
house and all this [ __ ] and we gotta
exchange gifts and all this [ __ ] i ain't
got no money no goddamn gift i'm so
ashamed anyway i wanted to go i thought
about i'm saying something i thought
about going just busting the
[ __ ] glass on the [ __ ]
window and then i said i know why they
doing this and you get free gifts and
[ __ ] i said what the [ __ ] if i go to
jail i'm gonna get kicked out my
[ __ ] apartment anyway [ __ ] em
man i couldn't do it so anyway i get
down to the [ __ ] house the
other day
i know i'm going to the i'm going to the
mission they guess i got home i ain't
got no [ __ ] food in the house i mean
my refrigerator is so empty the [ __ ]
ice won't even stay in it it's
i got three bottles of water and then
maybe a cold hamburger from last week
maybe a cold piece of chicken a steak
from the front of the people that
barking around the corner
there's two girls in a little green tent
in front of a mission now i'm standing
at the mission it's about this cold
[ __ ] it's in the rain
and some black girl comes up and she's
talking [ __ ] to these white girls in
this tent because they down in there and
she tell me it's finna get started finna
get cold
outside outside i'm i'm i'm sitting
looking and thinking i said i wanted to
see what they look when they get i want
to see what they look like
so they jumped out the tent they're
young as [ __ ] now they told me they were
a bit they i think one of them might
have been 19 of them might have been 20
22 they were they were they weren't they
weren't they weren't old enough young
enough to go to jail but they looked it
so anyway they got out and they were
standing there and and i and i walked
approached him i said well you girls
where you guys from he said we're from
whatever somewhere up there near lake
tahoe or something and they came down
and they got i don't know what they were
here and they didn't have anywhere to
stay and i said well look i said i got
my own apartment why don't you guys come
over they said we could be coobie so
we're running away to this apartment and
one of them tells me she says
i said
i saw him flicking a lighter i knew they
were doing so i thought they were small
bragging sit down maybe they gave me
some crack on his crack you know and
they weren't looking they were doing
crystal meth i don't really know that
much about that [ __ ] but anyway
the we're going to the house and she one
of the girls all of a sudden said we
were i said what you guys been doing
she's been there they said we got here
last night and we were talking crystal
and sucking each other's [ __ ] just come
out like that i said oh
so
that demonizing side of me he came up
and i looked at him i'm looking i'm i'm
sizing him up now it's moving that
little blind i'm gonna do her like this
and then it'll brunette i'll show the
brunette had big thighs like a black
girl and the blonde had a real nice
little round little button some nice
long legs you can see the the calves
sticking out of jeans i mean that's
they're nice they weren't that cute they
had a nice body so i knew i could want
them kind of smell like she needed a
bath i didn't give a [ __ ] you know i had
two girls you know so anyway to they
tell me that they would eat each other's
[ __ ] so they said well we need to stay
with you for a couple of days you know
we don't have any money we have some
drugs we don't have any money so i said
well just give me a little bit of
every now and then and you good to go
now we get to my apartment and i fellas
you know let me tell it i'm the biggest
i'm the gay man i'm the player lewis
lewis one i'm the player i'm i can do
women i can do 10 women already i'm the
big man the big shot
people know me let me tell me to tell
that lie
i got in the room with these two women
they pulled out the poopy they caught
that damn thing of pookie the crystal
they pulled the pookie out of the
[ __ ] pocket
one of them takes a hit she said turn on
the pornography well the darling got the
pornography
the point if you want to tell us won't
put it in their face got this black guy
getting a dick sucked by a white girl
she's looking at that so she takes the
top off and the blind goes can i suck
your [ __ ] she tells the brunette
and so they they doing the six you're
not laying on my bed doing this 69 now
this little blind girl comes out of her
[ __ ] shorts pulls on shorts down and
she sticks that little tight little
booty up in there she said come on baby
[ __ ] me
now i like to tell y'all most men would
have died on that [ __ ]
wait now wait hold on you guys are going
too fast now wait i wait wait wait i
can't
do it they went fast they just started
attacking each other
man i look i masturbate off that [ __ ]
and of the
movies but i never i've never had two
women i've had four in one day but never
two women at one time i had two
white girls and my mother [ __ ] made
every black man's fancy and they would
after me they wanted me and i for the
first for the first hour the first 30
minute time i couldn't get a woody
finally i said well i should watch the
weekly i said let me hit the crystal
whatever that [ __ ] is
i hit the [ __ ] crystal next
thing you know
i got my knee and one of them's [ __ ]
i'm sucking the other in this titty and
i'm telling her this is the [ __ ] i was
talking to her it all came i was like
yeah baby you like this big black
[ __ ] dick don't you you too
young to get [ __ ] but you liking it i
was telling you [ __ ] [ __ ] i was
talking to her like that oh yeah talking
to me baby talking to me baby she's
doing everything then all of a sudden
the brunette gets jealous
of what the bronze doing
i said wait a minute baby it's going to
be enough for me to go around but get
used to him i'll give her something
we we
we proceeded i mean i went man i've
i'm
six years old
i've never done i've never done anything
like that i mean i've never had to be
honest i've never had that much fun with
two women i mean i had five and i mean
it was it was about four o'clock in the
morning
and the brunette got chelsea got it
before lebron was in the bed and i'm
[ __ ] her [ __ ] heart though i
know the whole building heard her i was
10 hour 10 that ass up you know boom
boom boom so anyway i got to be about
got to be about five o'clock in the
morning
[ __ ] i'm burnt the [ __ ]
she looked like a demon man and she was
just looking at me with the with the
most darkest darkest look in the world
like she wanted to just utilize me
all of a sudden the [ __ ] wanted to
come out of their purse with a red
marker and put three sixes on their
forehead now look i got stick wait a
minute i was like
hold on
what the [ __ ] is going
we just want to do this while we suck
your dick one more last time i'm
thinking about my [ __ ] finna try to
bite my [ __ ] dick off
i said okay look i said i don't know
what y'all about i said i'm kind of
christian here i said my spirit don't
don't won't allow you to be up in my
room with no sixes on your head caught
my second we want to make my ball
another one suck my day
do you know they handed me the pipe hey
take another one i hit the pipe one more
time i didn't give a [ __ ] i had him down
i had him like this but what was really
going on inside of me
was how demoralizing how not
the the how not the the me the real real
other me is that i'm a pisces i have
literally
two different personalities one of my
personalities
this [ __ ] i got there's two
louises inside of me
one of them [ __ ] i don't like i
can't control him i can't contain him he
does what the [ __ ] he wants to do and i
kind of get therapy for that they said
you hear voices i hear voices i got the
other lord louis takes over sometimes
the other lewis was there
the other lewis was there he hadn't
treated him
he treated them women like they were
like he didn't i treated them women bad
and i loved every [ __ ] minute of it
but now that the other lures came back
i'm all [ __ ] up about it because now i
got some more [ __ ] to push down in my
stomach what i had i'm telling y'all
thank y'all guys i can tell it
that i had all this [ __ ] to push down in
me
but you know most people i'm telling you
guys are most people when they when they
think about christmas man it's a good
time and a whole time a good whole time
and i'm not a bad person man but when i
get under the influence of that [ __ ] i
get to thinking about what people did to
me when i was a kid and how that [ __ ]
[ __ ] me up in the head man that [ __ ]
got me [ __ ] up and it ain't all my
fault it's just what any one of you
[ __ ] but that's me as a kid
listen to this [ __ ] man [ __ ] you each
[ __ ] [ __ ] doc yeah you wanna
[ __ ] a kid up you [ __ ] this kid up not
only you [ __ ] this kid up you [ __ ] this
teenager you [ __ ] this grown up man you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] this [ __ ] gave me
two different personalities gave me
freaky ass actually freaky as mine and a
deep this d minor [ __ ] that i do on the
influence because of the [ __ ] and when i
come to holiday time that i get
depressed about i think about the [ __ ]
you did to me as a child so if you're
watching this [ __ ] man [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
your [ __ ] i hope i hope i see
you if i see you after again i'm gonna
beat this [ __ ] out of you i'm giving
[ __ ] me and woman whoever the [ __ ] you
was that's how i [ __ ] feel today
i'm really [ __ ] pissed off with you
[ __ ] look all my life's all
[ __ ] up on this goddamn [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
[ __ ]
anyway
i'm gonna have a good prince any guy
don't i could see see i'm telling some i
know i know i know for some some kind of
way i know how to deal with this [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
it it gets to the point where i don't
know how to deal with this [ __ ] but then
there's another point where i do know
how to deal with this [ __ ] that's some
deep ass [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean you
think i mean you think when you want
them less than another kid like you did
me you think about how you [ __ ] my life
for man cause my whole life is [ __ ] up
in that [ __ ] you [ __ ] kid up when
when you most kids that are out here
they out here because somebody and i
asked all the girls all of them been
molested all of them
been molested this kid one told me she
was three years old when she got me less
i said damn but i was five what's the
difference i mean i i i i was talk i was
talking because i could that's baby i
can identify with that you know and it
keeps me it keeps me dreaming keeps me
used you know because it's the only way
i have the point thing i have to come
back to combat the uh the the
the feeling the pain and the anger the
resentment and the frustration and
and and man i just did so much well i i
gave it all to y'all [ __ ] because i
haven't talked to nobody i was sitting
in my room where they think i said i
need i need to get back to youtube i
need to get back i need to get off of
some of this [ __ ] here
you know so
that's what i had to lay out there on
the platform for the day i got a whole
lot more i want to keep our all right
[ __ ] because all i'll be i'll
be here from now to june
so i'm going to come back
for sure and just hey man even the ones
i hate you dirty ass [ __ ] child
molesting [ __ ] ass [ __ ] you
have a [ __ ] merry christmas too
i'm gone thank you
you